- When I go to a music festival in LA,
people are naked, you know?
Everyone was staring and I
was just there in my one-piece
like oh okay, I'm really exposed now.
- And here we are.
(girls laughing)
(festive electronic music)
Hey guys, it's YB.
- And Herbert.
- We're in Belgium right now
and we're about to attend Tomorrowland
which is one of the biggest
EDM music festivals in the whole world.
I've gone to a lot of music festivals
since I was in high school,
because I really like electronic music.
Going to Tomorrowland has been my dream
and finally we had the opportunity to come
so I am so excited.
- [Herbert] Me too, as a European,
I have always heard a lot
of great things about it.
- So, this is a three day music festival
where everyone from all around the world
comes to party, it's crazy actually.
I've seen pictures where
everyone's holding flags
and it's literally the whole
world comes to party together.
We're gonna try the different
food and drinks here
and show you guys kind of how it is
and yeah, we're gonna party!
- It's gonna be a long weekend.
- Yeah, but probably the best ever.
We're excited, let's go! (laughs)
(deep house music)
So, we're inside Tomorrowland
and we got this little
card where we can put money in.
They have their own cashless
currency called Pearls
and festive goers can transfer
them onto their wristbands.
20 euros equal about 12.5 Pearls.
We also got a map so we know where to go.
As you can see, there are
16 stages which is crazy.
This is the biggest festival I've been to.
They also has this Tomorrowland app
where you can see the lineup
and check who's playing
where at which time.
I can even create my own schedule
by clicking on the hearts and
here's what I made for today.
(deep house music)
Cool thing, we have a
refreshment point here.
There are hair salons, tattoo shops,
as well as a bunch of food stands.
Pasta!
(deep house music)
- Had some Mai Tais!
(future bass music)
- Ladies and gentlemen, this is our home.
This is where we started,
this is Tomorrowland!
(people cheering)
- [YB] How long have you
been performing as DJs?
Yeah.
Wow!
How many years have you
played at Tomorrowland?
Yeah.
(DJ exclaiming)
Alright, day two.
My friend, Nikki, is here.
- Hi, everyone.
- One thing I have to warn you about is
we really have to walk a lot,
because there are 16 stages
and it's like a whole village.
- I'm ready.
- Yeah.
(progressive techno music)
The vibe here is truly amazing.
I've seen flags from all around the world
and it's definitely
different from the festivals
I've been to in America,
but most importantly, it's
about everyone coming together
in one place and enjoying it together.
(melodic electronic music)
How long have you been
playing at Tomorrowland?
Fourth year, nice.
(melodic electronic music)
Okay so it's day three
and it's the last day of Tomorrowland.
I can't believe we already did two days.
Are you surviving or how are you doing?
- I think more than three
days is not possible,
but today we will do our best.
- I think I can still party today,
although I am getting like a little tired.
(electronic guitar music)
So...
- Got some small eye rings already.
- I have eye rings?
You mean dark circles?
- You see my eye rings?
- Yesterday, we actually tried to find
one of the restaurants there,
because I heard Tomorrowland
is famous for having
actual really good restaurants on site
and apparently some of
them have Michelin star.
But, we went to a couple
of restaurants there,
because again it's so far from each other
that you have to walk so
much to get to one place
and we tried to find at least two of them,
but they were all booked
or closed already.
So, I think today that's
gonna be our goal,
to find the restaurant
we can actually eat in.
Yeah, early enough, but the food we had
at the food stands, we had
pasta again and you had pizza.
That was good.
- [Herbert] That was good.
- Yeah, so here's our last
day and hopefully we survive.
(progressive electronic music)
- Hands up, hands up, hands up!
- How long have you been
playing at Tomorrowland?
2013?
So it's been like six, seven years?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, wow!
Can you do the hum for us?
(Ummet humming)
(big room music)
- Tomorrowland, thank you so much!
(upbeat festive music)
- This is the fish.
So that was an amazing dinner,
I'm so glad we got to
experience this before we left
and now back to dancing.
(upbeat electronic music)
Every festival holds its
own special memory for me,
but Tomorrowland was a magical experience
I will cherish forever.
It was something I dreamed
of since high school
and finally attending
it meant so much to me.
Three days full of love, dancing,
new friends from all around the world,
and even getting to meet
some of my favorite DJs.
I'm so thankful I got to be a part of it.
I recommend it to anyone who loves music
and we'll definitely be back another year.
Thank you, Tomorrowland.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat electronic music)